thank you guys coming out and first
before I get started I did want to
address a few things somebody asked me
backstage they said the couple older
folks in here and do you change your
material for the age of the people who
are sitting in front of you
no I'm gonna tell you why
to my grandmother not that notion out of
me quick because the first time she saw
me I was super nervous I didn't want to
swear in front of her you know
so she catches me backstage and she goes
you you looking nervous I said I am I'm
really nervous and she said why are you
so nervous I said well I don't want to
swear in front of you Nana
and she said what word exactly do you
not want to say I said well I don't want
to say [ __ ] in front of you and she said
sweetheart
I had to [ __ ] for you to get here and I
was like
so the show and I had given you a ride
[ __ ]
I need you in the side of the road like
my grandson needs to work you know
well here's thing with my grandparents
and I will say this I learned a lot from
them about family first of all they were
so funny
and they always infused humor into
whatever we doing and they never used
the word inappropriate whoo it was funny
it was funny and I was like me I'm gonna
do that and they also were all about
family first that was a big thing I
learned from my grandparents his family
first and I think I really took that
into my family with my kids you know my
my youngest son he tells me everything
everything he told me the first time he
touched the boob he walks into my room
super serious and he walks in he goes
Hey I said what's up he goes boomer I
said what's going on he goes no no no no
no step outside now I'll tell you what I
thought was happening what I thought was
happening is I had thought he hit that
age that every man hits where they look
at their dad that first time and they
think I won't beat the [ __ ] out of this
dude but everybody looks they're down at
least once like Oh tell me to take out
the trash again so we're walking outside
I'm tightening up my shoelaces I'm like
oh it's [ __ ] on okay here we go
and I'm planning on just poking him in
the neck once really hard to slow him
down the [ __ ] you know cuz he's bigger
than me I need to slow him down he's a
big dude and we get outside and he goes
touch the boob and I say yeah what do
you think he goes warm definitely gonna
try to do that again so but now he did
try to fight me and I grew up with three
older brothers we all wrestled or fought
my dad at least once growing up anybody
in here wrestle or fight their dad
how old were you man held 12 not a lot
of muscle tone on a 12 year old 12 huh
how'd that go for you yeah you know what
you learn early on as a young man is
that your dad takes it way more
seriously than you do you right because
you're like I'm gonna mess with the old
man he's like what the [ __ ] yeah man I
listen by the way I asked some dude last
week I go how are you and you fight your
dad he goes thirty I was like holy Sh
let's just beating up an old man at that
point in time right but you know what he
said he goes yeah well it's the first
time I thought I had a shot so and I'm
not mad at him you going where you think
you got your shot you know but I
remember with my oldest brother the
first time he decided he was gonna fight
my dad right
so me and my other two brothers are in
my room we're all under the age of 10
I'm probably like six my oldest
brother's probably 16 and he walks into
the room super serious right he walks in
he's like I'm fighting dad today and I'm
six I'm like
you find dad that's right a button dad
you guys got my back and we were all
like you guys you guys ready for some
new rules like he goes what do you want
like you got it oh he was riding us up I
thought there was gonna be a regime
change everybody I needed to be on the
right side of that [ __ ] you know he had
us riled up I was grabbing pictures of
my dad off the wall like we're
downstairs following him he's like you
guys ready like you guys got my back we
got your back we get outside my dad's
and the patio and he's smoking a cigar
you sitting down my brother walks out
and he goes we're fighting at a old man
my dad my dad stands up videos okay now
hindsight being what it is my dad's
confidence should have been a bit of a
red flag for my brother
dude didn't even take the cigar out of
his [ __ ] mouth
he knew he wasn't getting hit you know
what I mean like if you go to a fight
and one of the guys has a cigar in his
mouth that's the [ __ ] winner
that guy is like I am confident as [ __ ]
so my brother goes and let me tell you
something and before he could get
another word out of his [ __ ] mouth my
dad kicked him in the nuts so he fell on
the ground
[ __ ] up to him he goes you know you
shouldn't talk to your fight right and
walk in the house like a [ __ ]
gangster and we all want
I'm not hanging outside with a loser I'm
going to sack the winner like I'm not
stupid you know
[Music]
[Music]